hi there now I'm Aria and today I'm
gonna be dribbling a football or soccer
ball all day today why am I doing this
because my good buddy Zach challenged me
too and I've also got nothing going on
Zach also promised me football tickets
if I'm able to successfully complete
this challenge which would be delightful
it sounds very easy but I know this
sneaky man and I know he's got some
tricks up his sleeve so what to see how
the day goes
oh what a way to begin
[Music]
ah the canteen my domain Chris Rachel
bananas I'm sweating already
you know I saw your video you know
basketball I don't want to get screwed
over like you were I'm here earlier then
I wouldn't be on a workday
I feel good so far you know it easy but
I know Zach's got some tricks coming to
my desk is unfortunately upstairs which
I'm fairly certain that Zach knew this
unfortunately I don't think I'm allowed
to just kick it up there cuz there's
someone sitting there I don't want to
you know HR already has a whole file on
me but I do have a bit of sneaky plans
there was a Mexican footballer named
Blanco he perform a trick at the World
Cup which has since been dubbed the
Blanco bounce or the kangaroo hop so I'm
gonna try try going up that way
[Music]
for them to work out this funds keeping
me active have not played with the ball
at my feet for for a few years now and
it's definitely caught up to me what's
life without a little challenge that you
make yourself
so what aria doesn't know is that I set
up a series of challenges for him today
because if he just dribbles a ball all
day that's a little too easy I'm just
gonna have to like immediately give him
the tickets so I set up a series of
challenges for him today with the finale
being penalty kicks
we'll see what he can do what are you
doing here today
Oh time for your first challenge no
we're gonna do you are gonna get one
point for every time you can
successfully juggle the ball that's
risky for me
let's see what I've played it in school
I was terrible at juggling so this is
gonna be embarrassing but we're gonna
get at least three points here
I feel like three isn't that confident
you'll see no funny business once you
get those Amazon Amazon all right let's
try this stuff got three baby warning
this is a warning why you hit the
cameraman no that was accidental please
please please a warning I'm not giving
it to him good morning mother
I'm warning you on language oh come on
we gotta edit bleep these out every
single time I will not swear the rest of
the day every time I swear I'll be
donating $10 to a charity of Zak
Christmas choosing Oh
[Applause]
hey that was good you got 10 12 or
something Aria told him to be here by
now and he's not here I'm gonna give him
a card this is late hey dude
happy to see me won't you come here okay
you know what this is a good hard I hate
to do this you're you're late you're
late I told you to be here at noon
it's 1204 we're gonna let you eat food
but I have a challenge for you you need
to perform a five giving those just the
the nice employees here so basically you
need to pass it and get it passed back
to you okay five times and then you need
to get your lunch I don't know most of
these people so that's what yeah Oh guys
fine just five you do me a favor
are there could you pass the ball back
and forth for me just once you do it you
can either you thank you thank you pass
this with me one do this to you to
youtube that one doesn't count she was
on defense she's good pass the ball with
me one or two more
yeah thank you sir I can eat very
successful yeah now just go ahead and
get your food but you have to keep
tripling it what'd I say about language
I apologize it's quite tedious time to
have this around quite hard I keep
spilling everywhere so I have got them
oh please don't break that plate I
already mentioned that hey I got a new
challenge for you oh yeah oh you know
soccer mmm football yes people running
around it gets tough out there they get
hit and injuries happens yeah sometimes
they sell it you know what I'm gonna
need you to do just go around the office
and you need to fake an injury and you
need to successfully sound like injured
South to something that's no fun for me
either two years Community College
theater okay Santa Monica College go
Corsairs Spencer
don't touch the desk I don't think she
was convinced so we have to try someone
else my friend Meghan sits in the back
corner over there I think I can make her
fall for it when it comes to I also want
to show you some tricks supposed to show
someone tricks I'm gonna try and do some
culture today okay watch this ya know
Kazak challenged me to to stage an
injury where you fool to with injured
Thank You Meghan
there are probably videos of people
spending a very prolonged amount of time
training to do this trick and who want
me to do it in the few minutes sure I
was never able to pull off any kind
trick like this when I when I play it so
it might happen there's a surprise
challenge we knew you wouldn't be able
to do that he was locking eyes on you
for this whole thing and then he just
went for it
good good job good job every time I
think you're gonna thank you getting up
something you do for you oh you got it
back over there momentarily
one last thing I'm happy to do whatever
you need me to do baby I'm gonna have
you try to score a goal on a goalie this
guy yep Zack he was a he played college
level football I hope you know this yeah
alright you know he's got a score once
just once all right all right
here we are the final challenge that I
didn't think you would even get I've
been so little nervous yeah I've all I
this is quite a location you've chosen
yeah you know I went for something
that's a little more grungy yeah yeah
people stroll a little more free a lot
of challenges surprises yes so I'm
feeling generous I'm going to let you
try twice and you only have to make one
I just gotta make one to win and those
tickets are mine I wanna alright Zach
how you feeling less confident
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I'm gonna make so many friends a
stadium full of friends your animal this
guy yeah it was a long day
it was tedious at times but honestly how
awfully can you say that you spent a
whole workday drilled on the ball around
your office I also got free tickets now
to go see a football game
well it's been a few days and it's
acting through the tickets pleasantly
surprised
time to make some friends
[Music]